Jamie Hale is a wheelchair user who's
relied on Britain's National Health
Service or NHS for most of his life
without a viable NHS I wouldn't be here
and if the NHS collapses I don't
particularly credit my chances
in April he decided to undergo major
surgery five months later he's still
waiting for it to be scheduled it's
difficult and frustrating it impacts on
the way I can live my life the amount of
pain and discomfort I'm in during the
last round of strikes in may Jamie had
another procedure delayed two weeks one
of a million medical appointments
postponed since December thanks to
healthcare strikes Hospital leaders and
public health officials call the current
situation dangerous sworn in continued
strikes create an enormous challenge
the strikes this week represent the
biggest industrial disruption to
Britain's nationalized Health Service in
its history they will mean longer delays
for patients already waiting months for
treatment or surgery but they also
highlight a Workforce and a system
that's close to Breaking Point
senior doctors in England began striking
Tuesday on Wednesday Junior doctors
joined them leaving just limited Medical
cover Nationwide and on Thursday and
Friday tens of thousands of Junior
doctors will provide no service at all
senior doctors have seen their pay full
17 in real term since 2010. the
government this year suggested a six
percent increase Junior doctors also saw
a drop of up to 17 during the same
period they were recently offered a nine
percent uplift
two in three UK doctors belong to the
British Medical Association behind this
strike including Dr Arjun nagra a London
doctor early in his career the strength
of kind of the unity that we've got
amongst us is at an all-time high and
that's only because doctors realize this
is the Last Chance Saloon for us it's
kind of the last throw of the dice it's
no one ever to save our profession in
this country and to restore it
Britain's Health Minister hasn't held
talks on pay for six months and this
week announced plans to force doctors
back to work prime minister has been
clear the position for pay this year has
it been agreed through the pre-review
building process and that is the
government's position despite the delays
Jaime faces like many British residents
he still supports the doctor's demands
that's what I care about is knowing that
there'll be an NHS in 5 10 15 years time
not whether I end up waiting another
month now
many similar sacrifices may be made this
week but without higher salaries there
remain no Simple Solutions villain marks
Al Jazeera London